that this um did he survive this tragic
collision
and i'd like to point out that tiger
wood and his representatives have been
very cooperative throughout this
investigative process
and they've also provided us with the
permission to share these findings with
you
and for the record under section 2001 to
the california vehicle code
the details of this report would remain
confidential
except for the involved parties and this
is true of the thousands of reports like
this type
repair pair every year throughout l.a
county
and no one is asking for any of those
reports and so this is treated no
differently
the primary causal factor for this
traffic collision was driving at a speed
unsafe for the road conditions and the
inability to negotiate
the curve of the roadway estimated
speeds at the first area of impact were
the curve of the roadway estimated
speeds at the first area of impact were
84 to 87 miles per hour
and the final estimated speed when the
vehicle struck the tree was 75 miles per
hour
there were no citations issued and there
are no signs of impairment
now i know there are some saying somehow
he received a special or a preferential
treatment any
any of some kind that is absolutely
false
there was no signs of impairment our
primary concern once we
obviously at the scene of the collision
was uh his his safety
and this is where you you have to switch
gears and make sure
the person can survive and it receives
the medical care they need
and the fire department paramedics and
that's why he was taken to a trauma
center because he obviously had compound
fracture to a leg and it was
life-threatening injuries
so i know there's a
lot of experts who claim their drug
recognition
people said oh they should have done
drawn blood or done this or done that
and without the signs of impairment we
don't get to the point where we can
actually
author a search warrant and develop the
probable cause to get that and execute
that search warrant so that did not
happen and that is not preferential
treatment
that would occur in any collision of
this type based on these circumstances
and past history does not get you the
elements you need to establish their
probable cause so
i'll leave it at that so now let me
introduce jim powers who's the captain
of lomita sheriff station
thank you sheriff thank you for having
me here
good morning uh i'm here to discuss the
uh some of the details of the traffic
collision that occurred
on tuesday february 23rd of this year at
approximately 7 12 in the morning
on hawthorne boulevard in the city of
rolling hills estates involving mr tiger
woods
i'd like to first introduce the deputies
that were involved in this investigation
the first responding deputy is deputy
carlos gonzalez who is to my
right also deputy justin smith who was
uh
involved in the investigation after the
fact and the the lead investigator
detective johan shlogo
and then sergeant michael dowling
downing from uh
traffic services bureau was involved
in the evaluation of the the data
recorder of the vehicle
so upon our arrival when mr woods was
involved in the collision
we responded the vehicle was off the
roadway and on its side
mr woods was still inside the vehicle
his seatbelt was still worn
and the airbags had deployed
mr wood appeared injured based on his
appearance and to prevent further injury
we waited for the paramedics to arrive
to remove him from the vehicle
and transport to the transport him to
the hospital
um there should be a slight of an area
of view the uh
the median is depicted on the slide
where the first area of impact was
there's a sign on the median that was
the second area of impact which is
depicted by
red dots and then the third area of
impact
was on the west curb on the opposite
side of hawthorne boulevard
and then the fourth era of impact was a
tree west of the curb
uh on the off the roadway approximately
71 feet
and the blue dot that's indicated there
is where the point of rest where the
vehicle was
the impact of the vehicle when they hit
the tree caused the vehicle to go
airborne
and do a somewhat pirouette landing on
its side
the follow-up investigation after the
fact as the sheriff indicated there was
no evidence of any impairment
there was no odor of alcohol there were
no open containers in the vehicle
and there were no narcotics or any
evidence of medication
in the vehicle or on his person in this
situation the question was asked about
did we conduct field sobriety tests
due to his injuries and the traumatic uh
nature of his injuries it would not be
appropriate to do any type of field
sobriety test
i will say that tiger woods and his
management team have been in
communication with us
and have been throughout this entire
event and have cooperated with
any of our follow-up investigation
questions and have responded to any of
our questions
and or concerns the event data recorder
was
in it was investigated and on march 1st
we we examined that data recorder uh
after obtaining a search warrant
uh that was signed by uh judge tony cho
of the torrance courthouse
there's an airbag control unit of the
data recorder that showed
information that we described as event
one
and event two and a combination of event
one
and two those events are areas of impact
that was recorded by the recorder the
airbags were deployed
and each event shows a five-second
window
and the combination of both events show
a
a seven second window uh prior to the
collision and up to the collision
the event data recorder showed speeds
ranged from 82.02 miles per hour
to 86.99 miles per hour
and back down to 68.35 miles per hour
a second reading of this event data
recorder is the acceleration pedal
percentage
which is uh the pressure applied to the
accelerator pedal
during the collision this measurement
was at 99 percent
at the area of impact at all the area of
impacts of the collision
the data recorder also recorded braking
there was no evidence of braking
throughout this collision it is
speculated and believed that tiger woods
inadvertently hit the accelerator
instead of the brake pedal
causing that 99 rating on the
accelerator pedal
steering was also recorded and it ranged
from a minus 10
to 55 and this is on a 360 degree
circular model so it indicates that
stirring was made from the left and to
the right
and it's believed that this could be
from trying to correct from the impacts
and also the impacts itself throughout
the collision
again the estimated speeds of impact
were 84 to 87 miles per hour at the
median
84 uh and and then at the impact of the
west curb line
it's estimated the speed was about 75
miles per hour
and these are estimated speeds based on
the recordings from the data recorder
the cause of collision is determined by
the statements of the parties involved
any independent witnesses facts of the
scene and roadway
and the opinions of the traffic
investigators there were no independent
witnesses of this collision
and the primary cause was driving at a
speed unsafe for the road conditions
and the inability to locate to negotiate
the curve of the roadway
no citation was issued and there were no
independent voices and no
observations by a peace officer which
would support the issue
issuance of a citation and uh
that's all i have and if you have any
questions we welcome them
so you want to answer does the
sharepoint ask first
question that's fine captain thank you
elizabeth captain
um was there any evidence of
distracted driving i mean did you check
his phone for any texting or anything
like that
we did not check his phone for texting
and there was really no need for to to
do that
um and so there the only there was no
other evidence the the only associated
factor
well there's there's two factors this
the speed and the and the failing to
maintain the the straight course of the
the
curvature of the roadway that's it
there's there's nothing from a cell
phone to indicate any type of distracted
driving
or phone calls or anything not to our
knowledge
what about blood work and there was a
lot made about being able to drop load
of the scene which i know was
preposterous but
the uh the notion that if you did have
access to blood work to the hospital did
you
keep a warrant for that at all we did
not seek a warrant because there was no
indication for us to do so and and so
based on all the facts there was no
evidence of any impairment or
intoxication
and so in order to obtain a search
warrant you have to have probable cause
you'll be able to articulate that
and that did not exist
we have our investigators out there and
they are qualified dres and and so those
questions were asked
and they're they're they're all
indicated and documented in the report
can you explain that one more time it's
believed that
um when you panic
or you have some sort of a sudden
interruption while you're driving
uh your your initial uh
impact is or your initial thought is to
hit the brake and it's believed that
he may have done that but hit the
accelerator and didn't hit the brake
we don't know that he doesn't have any
recollection of the of the incident
and like i said that's a speculation
there's zero breaking
uh throughout that recording of the data
recorder and it's 99
acceleration on the
to check to see pedal tiger was perhaps
distracted using a cell phone or texting
before the accident
it's no but my investigators
as they as they interviewed him at the
scene
and at the hospital the questions were
asked and there was nothing to indicate
any type of intoxication he he did
answer those questions he did not
he stated he didn't drink he didn't
there's nothing he's not under he wasn't
taking any medication
so those questions were asked and
answered was there any reason
at this time we're going to open it up
to the phones
thank you ladies and gentlemen if you
have a question on the phone line please
press one
zero on your telephone keypad
captain this yellow line is that an
accurate depiction of this and our first
question comes from
craig bigner that's an estimate with knx
news radio
please go ahead hi good morning thank
you for taking the
call i want to know based on this
vehicle
and the way it's configured it did have
some ability
for autonomous driving or autonomous
[Music]
capabilities do we know if any of those
were in use
at the time of this collision or before
we do not know that answer that question
and we did not retrieve any of the
information like that from the data
recorder
captain i think that car is equipped
with cameras too do you know if they
were rolling on this thing
which camera sir i believe that car can
be equipped with cameras like the
dash cam i don't believe that car had
any cameras equipped
captain we wouldn't give any reason for
the incentive
no he he has no recollection that
collision so he he's not even aware of
the speed until it was presented in
describe this case for that situation
it's unsafe for the conditions just just
like the vehicle code reads
um the speed limit posted is 45 miles
per hour
and he was driving in excess of that and
it caused the collision so it's unsafe
before the collision no i do not all i
know is a seven second window
uh from that was recovered from the
recorder can you explain why there's not
a citation if he was driving
part of it was because of the uh the
circumstances that he
he endured throughout the collision and
the fact that in order to
issue a citation it usually you have to
have something to indicate
an independent witness or an observation
by a peace officer
and so i can't just inadvertently go out
and write tickets and uh
it's i mean you can do it but it would
be kind of
i don't want to say a waste of time but
a lot of the courts will dismiss it
because there's
it wasn't observed by a peace officer
captain had somebody else been injured
in this crash how different would this
investigation be what kind of questions
people wanted to look for now well if
there is a
significant injury or fatality then we
definitely would have investigated it
further
do you think you asked enough questions
and you got enough answers from tiger
woods
absolutely captain did he try and
correct his steering at all or was it
basically straight off the road like
this um there there's indication of
of stirring whereas i gave the the
examples of the strings so there was
there was steering in the vehicle uh at
the areas of impact
and it's unsure it's unsure if it was
him trying to correct the situation
or if it was the impact the vehicle at
the areas of impact that caused that by
the movement of the vehicle
i'm sorry the first impact he drove
right into it wasn't even correct at all
it's a raised median so there was impact
and it did
it did have an impact on the vehicle yes
can you tell us a little bit about your
conversations with tiger woods in the
moments that led up to the accident what
he remembers what he doesn't recall
i can in what i've reviewed in this
situation
he's in a state of shock at the onset of
that collision
he was awake we helped him sit up a
little bit
and then we tried to extract him from
the vehicle
by breaking the sunroof and it wouldn't
break and so we waited for the fire
department
so he was um i i don't want to use the
word alert but he was
but he was kind of dazed and confused
being in the state of shock
and then he was interviewed at the
hospital as well and he was uh he was
coherent
his speech was normal and uh there's
there are interviews of him at the
hospital where he's
answering questions um in the in the
emergency room my question is leading up
to the car accident what he remembers
doing
moments before the car accident what did
he say that he remembered before
i i don't i don't have the answer to
that question
if he was distracted well i i know that
um
i i i know that there was allegations of
an incident that occurred prior to the
collision
which i reviewed video footage and
he was um i i watched him on video
walk out to his car put his personal
belongings in his car
and drive off the property and he was uh
driving very normal very slow
as he as he began driving to the point
where he doesn't it didn't appear that
he even hit the accelerator they
took his foot off the brake and allowed
the car to roll away he made complete
stops at two stop signs
and stopped for a traffic signal before
entering the highway and
and so there's there's no evidence of
any uh increased speed
or uh rush behavior i guess leading up
to the crash though was tiger woods
late to an appointment was he on his
cell phone what did he tell you about
the moments leading up to the crash why
he may have been traveling at that speed
i don't believe he recalls that
the so the the you know i the only
statement i recall
uh seen in the report is that he had a
long day of the day prior
we can take another question uh from a
caller
thank you our next question on the phone
comes from brendan
giaffrion with tmz please go ahead
hi sharon uh there the sheriff said the
day after the accident
no crime was committed this is speeding
and reckless driving that we're
talking about so how did you arrive at
the conclusion that there was no crime
well speeding is an infraction
and it's not uh criminal nature like a
misdemeanor or a felony and there's no
evidence of reckless driving so that
that statement was never made
another question is if tiger was driving
85 to 87 miles an hour in a 45 zone why
not ticket for reckless driving because
reckless driving you have to have
multiple violations
uh consider in conjunction with one
another like multiple unsafe lane
changes uh
passing vehicles in an unsafe manner
kind of like
road race stuff and that did not exist
here therefore reckless driving is not
not appropriate
and the speeding uh there's the speeding
there was no independent witnesses
regarding the speeding and it wasn't
observed by a peace officer so
no citation was issued captain last
question for you in your opinion did
tiger make a conscious effort
to avoid the accident i don't we don't
know that
how often is that the case who is walked
away without the citation when you
consider
other drivers and crashes similar to
this how often is that
that they are not cited later because of
the assessment
each case is is uh is decided on an
individual basis
case-by-case basis and so in situations
like this
it's it's a i mean it just
the decision was made not to issue a
citation that's that's it
well as i stated there was no
independent witness to support that
that saw the violation and there's no
deputy sheriffs or peace officers that
witnessed the violation
let me add to that real quick the
decision not to issue a citation would
be the exact same thing for anyone in
this room who went through the same
situation
a solo traffic collision there's no
witness it's an infraction only
and we're not going to issue a citation
on infraction not committed in
peace officers presence or independent
witnesses period that apply to everybody
so any inference that somehow is special
is false despite the evidence you have
on the event data reporter
the event data recorder that tells us
physically what happened but
we need a human being to witness it
there's quite a bit of discussion after
this accident about
this particular stretch of roadway yes
there's been adjustments made on the
roadway
and how much of this accident did you
blame on the roadway versus
the driver well this stretch of
particular roadway i believe we spoke a
few weeks ago that it had i think was it
13 or 14
14 of traffic collisions if you're going
like a quarter mile prior to quarter
mile after that stretch of roadway in
particular so it is
hazardous it encourages it just by the
design
it's straight away going downhill into a
curve people are approaching it with way
too much speed for the conditions the
road
this has been brought to the attention
to the supervisor uh
janice honest in her district and they
are
trying to address that with some ways of
traffic control to slow down the speed
how much do you blame that particular
roadway for this crash
versus the driver well it's the driver
bears a responsibility regardless of the
roadway as long as the roadway
is designed with the basics however
this stretch of roadway in particular
has a little bit more than average share
of collisions so they need to rethink
how this is designed and what we can do
to slow down
woods the traffic involved with another
vehicle if he had injured somebody would
he be facing some pretty criminal
serious criminal charges
on the same uh conditions uh no
it uh if there was an issue of an
impairment or reckless driving and then
by extension there's a victim from
another vehicle then there would be a
consideration but we don't have either
reckless driving we don't have any
evidence of impairment so
no that would not
were testing the apply to apply for a
search warrant you have to have probable
cause
and to get probable cause you need to
have a building blocks of elements to
indicate that someone
uh potentially committed a crime and
that's higher than just a reasonable
suspicion
and we do not have those building blocks
to get to a probable cause
so therefore you cannot approach a judge
with a search warrant
just because well we knew he had trouble
in the past or something therefore
can you sign this and the judge is going
to say get out of here
all right at this time it's uh going to
transition to spanish
will you be able to answer questions
non-crash related
sure thank you all right
[Music]
is
foreign
i was watching a town hall meeting the
other day with uh supervisor holly
mitchell
in which she referred to the leaders of
the da's association
association law enforcement in la
county's white supremacists
i just wanted to know if you had a
comment on that well those comments i
don't expect them from a responsible
elected official in los angeles county
or anywhere in this nation
it's uh reprehensible irresponsible
and i think uh that supervisor owes an
apology an awful lot of people who
dedicate their lives to uh
preserving public safety the public
peace and put their lives on the line
and to
you know paint them with a broad brush
of white supremacists
is just totally uncalled for it's
unprofessional do you suppose these
kinds of comments coming from elected
officials
will drive some sort of public sentiment
well it does it drives a narrative for
people that
already have an animus towards law
enforcement which makes the job of
of deputies and police officers out
there
contacting the people that don't want to
go to jail to begin with when they're in
the act of committing a violent crime
now they have uh more uh
they somehow feel that now they have a
supervisor back in their play that they
can resist
being arrested even though they're
committing a crime so this does not help
officer safety out there in the field
and all it does is it continues a spiral
of conflict between community members
in law enforcement it does not serve the
public's interest at all
for easter weekend there were 11
homicides in los angeles county
that's probably one of the highest on
easter weekend
well the crime continues to spiral out
of control particularly violent crime
and our homeless situation is spiraling
out of control i need supervisors to
start focusing on violent crime in our
homeless situation those are the twin
crisis
that is important to every single
resident of los angeles county and
you know to take cheap shots that law
enforcement for you what you perceive to
be a political gain does not solve
either those two problems so our our job
my job is to focus on
violent crime in the homeless situation
and i expect everyone else to do the
same from city hall
board of supervisors governor's office
we need to get busy now because uh the
problems are real
and uh just trying to you know trying to
fan the flames of political divisions
does not
solve any of these problems last
question violent crime is up in los
angeles county
homicides alone we have measured them on
monday 152
which under ordinary times is people
would say oh my god that's extraordinary
it's a crisis it is a crisis
unfortunately the times we live today
there's people that think
so what who cares they still have their
agenda and they're just going to ignore
people dying left and right around them
we're not going to ignore that do you
have a number to tie to that i'm sorry
do you have a number to tie to that 115
uh you i do have the number we can
provide for you yes
i just saw the chart on monday and it's
actually went up for 133
152 that's prior to calculating
this weekend last question
was the airbags that went off do we know
if the airbags went off when we hit the
center divide or when it
did there was multiple airbags or did
they go out after we hit the tree
well typically the airbags depend on
what type of sensor they have there's
sensors that are a bumper
and they're impact generated and those
make everything go off there other ones
that are
a little higher end that are they sense
a loss of inertia
and then they deploy so i don't know if
you know which type of
it's believed that this is the sidewalk
in the tree started walking the tree
all right so there you go
when they hit the sidewalk in the tree
yes final question will be from our last
caller
thank you that will come from the line
of haley winslow with fox la please go
ahead
hey sheriff thank you so much i'm just
wondering about the body cam footage
from the deputies who responded to
tiger's crash will that be released
are we going to reuse that no i believe
not
and i think at that point all this is
going to show as a badly injured person
they have their their privacy issues
that
we'll respect that right
can you leave the graphics though thank
you yes we'll leave the graphics up
all right all right thank you
all right thank you that concludes the
press conference have a great day
oh
foreign